Throughout evolution, humans brains have grown larger and more complex. And
that allows us to do all the amazing things that we can do. Everything about
who we are, what we like, how we think, what we dream. And even how we feel is
a function of our brain and its electrical and chemical activities. The nervous
system is divided into the central nervous system that is comprised of the
brain and the spinal cord. And the peripheral nervous system that consists of
the somatic nervous system, which controls voluntary behavior. And the
autonomic nervous system that controls involuntary behavior. The autonomic
nervous system is further broken down into the sympathetic nervous system,
which is our fight or flight responses. And the parasympathetic nervous system,
which produces the opposite effects and relaxes the sympathetic nervous system.
Neurons are specialized cells that communicate with each other via electrical
and chemical signals. Sensory neurons receives sensory information and send it
to the brain for processing. The brain then sends information to our motor
neurons that allow us respond appropriately, and the interneurons form
connections between neurons. After an action potential has occurred, neurons
can release neurotransmitters, which are naturally occurring chemicals that
produce a cascade of effects. Some important neurotransmitters in the study of
psychology are, Dopamine, Serotonin, Acetycholine, Gabba, and Glutamate. As
well as our natural occurring Endorphins. The brain is divided into twp
hemispheres, left and right. And those communicate via the corpus collosum. The
upper-most portion of the brain is the cerebrum. And the frontal lobe is
important for attention, working memory, impulse control, and abstract thinking
and creativity. It is the youngest part of the brain and the part that makes us
most human. We are better able to determine what the different parts of the
brain are responsible for due to advances in brain imaging techniques such as
EEG, fMRI, and PET scans. These allow for researchers to see what parts of the
brain are activated when we engage in various activities, such as talking,
reading or even dreaming.